hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I'm your co-host
Geo I'm Bart what up Bart what up Geo
okay so
um I recently came across a JK news
video where well it's a real like a
shorter clip yeah on Instagram and
[Music]
everyone was going so it's it's the
careful boys so it's Nick Dunn Bart Quan
Anthony Lee Steve Green Ryan and may
comfortable bravado and JoJo right the
six of you guys yeah
um and on this Jay can you guys are
talking about just different topics and
stuff and and then it gets really
personal and I think everyone was going
around the room and talking about
um things that they were insecure about
and I think Anthony was hosting and he
asks the room about any insecurities
that anyone has and then like you put
your hand up
and you wished you were taller is that
what I said yeah I don't even remember
okay
so what the [__] are you insecure about
that or not because you said you weren't
secure about that that's what I wanted
to talk about yeah but you know when
you're in the moment just anything that
happens you're saying you can lie so
you're basically lying no no in the
moment that's what I was insecure about
maybe maybe right now I might be
insecure about something else that
doesn't make sense you're insecure about
something and it just you're insecure
about it yeah either until you get over
it but like what do you I don't even
understand what you're saying what would
you uh literally yeah that's what
happened to my brain I went uh what the
[__] are you talking about it's like you
like uh like when I ask you what do you
want to eat and you go I don't know what
I want to eat I just know what I don't
want to eat so every single time it's
like sometimes you want Mexican
sometimes you want Italians yeah but I'm
not insecure about different yeah but
it's different every time right it's a
different flavor no people are the
different flavors different times you
know what I'm saying
so sometimes I'm insecure about this
sometimes I'm insecure about that
so like I was insecure I don't even know
if insecure I guess insecure's the right
word I was insecure about my small boobs
yeah right because I have an image of
who I wanted to look like and what that
like who I wanted to become yeah right
yeah uh mentally physically all of that
who what woman I wanted to become like
when you're like five or something yeah
or like my teenage years I'm like this
is this when I see Geo in the future
this is what she looks like pretty
normal this is what she's driving this
is her you know significant other like I
just had all of that's very normal a lot
of people and they're like young they
just have a vision a vision board of who
they want to be and become and all that
yeah do you have a vision board now
uh no I actually don't oh okay I still
have
still haven't we'll get back to that
yeah wow we'll get back to that later
um so on my board at that age
I was like
um my boobs is one of them so I can do
everything I possibly can to like make
my brain bigger make my body uh you know
uh harder like there's things I can do
to change those right I couldn't change
my boobs other than cosmetic surgery
have you tried everything
to make them bigger the size I wanted
there's nothing that can do that there's
no like ointment
no none of that okay so that was my
insecurity therefore I changed it right
so I have a lot of these insecurities
and I changed them like I wanna I don't
want to be dumb I change that I don't
want to be I'm still working on it very
good yeah yeah I haven't stopped just
didn't want you to think I think I got
there yeah I got it bro okay tone it
down but so I say all that to say that
it never leaves right maybe it can grow
out of it but I don't ever go back and
forth I'm not like today I I love my
boobs they're the best boobs ever and
then I go oh man I hate them it's
usually pretty consistent for me if it's
one thing I am insecure about I either
learn how to love it or deal with it or
I change it yeah I don't go back and
forth like what you're saying like one
day I want Mexican the next day I want a
[__] Philly cheesesteak oh yeah I'm
not insecure about my height you
literally said you're insecure about
your height I think uh maybe I I
misunderstood the question either then
now but it was more so like if you could
change something about you what would
you change and for me it was height
I gotta find that oh but I'm not
insecure about it
is that what that is I gotta look it up
now keep talking because I just gotta
prove myself wrong are you wrong no I
literally that's that's what it is it I
think I either I misinterpreted what was
said now or or before but it was what
would you change and I was like oh yeah
I would totally add like anywhere
between two to three to four to six
inches oh man
well but why why do you ask that well
because I was just really taken aback
that you would even have an insecurity
like that because yes
um we all have insecurities and I
understand that you have insecurities
right like you're insecure if you don't
know how to defend yourself are you
insecure if you're insecure about of
course because it's valid and it makes
sense but when it comes to
um like physical attributes about
yourself you don't give a [__] I do
because that's not part of my vision
board
like Cornelius five
I thought I was I was gonna be like a
super dope athletic dude I thought I was
gonna be like six two yeah and then um
God shortchanged me like when did you
think you were gonna be good 12 inches
when did you think you were gonna be six
feet tall well so
um when I did kung fu my sifu's son yeah
he was kind of like my role model like
he was like my local Michael Jordan if
you will yeah and uh he was a tall dude
like he played water polo and uh he
talked to you at that age
I just knew it was tall okay but as a
kid like I would see him grow up with me
right like I'm like five he might have
been 10 or something and then as I got
to ten he was 15 so like I saw him grow
up with me yeah and then I was like oh
he's an adult like when you do kung fu
and you look good and you're athletic
like he's an adult and I my Seafood was
like 5 10. so I saw him surpassing my
seafood and get taller and taller and he
would like broad shoulders and he like
started playing water polo and he was
just like a stud muffin and I was like
okay cool that's a stud muffin I want to
be a stud muffin yeah and then so here
comes me in high school I'm like I'm
like five two I'm like all right here it
comes here it comes everybody just watch
out you know and then like my like
Junior here here it comes five six oh
boy I'm real close getting close to that
six foot two you know and then like I
get to like senior year and I'm like oh
five seven everybody just watch out here
it comes and then and then and then it
was like one of those things where like
you light the firework and you run like
10 feet aside and like this it's a dud
and it's like
you're like all right here we go five
eight five nine I know we got the good
five more inches it's gonna go boom
everyone just watch out and then now I'm
38 and but I'm sorry I'll tell you
someone for the boom you're five nine
five eight five nine I don't know five
eight could be could be either of those
I've been measured I've been measured by
both before
I've I've always teetered on five
honestly closer to five ten uh five
eleven because I've been like five ten
and three quarters so I'm just like all
right I'm [__] five eleven okay
depends on when I get measured I don't
know yeah yeah I know you're taller in
the morning but
um
yeah height was never something I even
paid attention to
well because you always have it one and
I didn't even know I was tall right
because if you have too much of it
especially as a girl it's like a rich
guy's here I never had money I just
never worried about it yeah no but for a
girl it's not like a desirable thing
every girl wants to be taught okay it'll
be long and slender you want to be a
model that's true that's true that's
true that's true did you just call me a
model
yeah of course I love you you're
beautiful oh [__] thanks nah well I
don't know two podcasts ago you were
talking about how I'm disgusting but
it's okay
[Music]
okay well
so you didn't get it was it something
that like you carried with yourself like
did it prevent you did it make you sad
in any type of way or you were like [__]
yeah really yeah
did you know I actually took growth
pills before
no yeah
I took growth pills what the for your
dick no I know you had a penis pump I'd
have a penis pump too okay we'll get to
that story so when I was uh I didn't
know this about you you [__] loser
you're a [__] loser when I was 18.
[__] loser you were 18 dude when I
was 18.
um I was in the military right okay and
you're very familiar with my best friend
yeah I'm very familiar so we went to
boot camp together yeah and then we got
uh it was lucky for us to go to MOS
School even though we had different
Moses which is our jobs it was different
jobs but it was at the same base okay so
we got really lucky which is super cool
uh we got to hang out together so we had
a plan we were like what if this is our
chance to completely revamp ourselves
and then come back
uh come back to the the to the hood like
yeah no to the homies right yeah yeah so
we're like okay cool what are we gonna
do so like okay let's get jacked because
we got we came out of boot camp skinny
as [__] I went into boot camp 165 I came
out 1 30. oh I was only 130 pounds
[__] lost all muscle everything right
he probably you had a lot of muscle
before when you went in uh 165 was not
bad that doesn't mean you have muscle oh
I had muscle I guess because I I was
uplifting are you liking Fitness or
something
now I am okay my best friend he's six
feet tall uh and he graduated I think
weighing like 145 or something and he's
six feet you know so we come out [__]
just Skin and Bones let's revamp
ourselves so we uh would go to the chow
hall which is where you get food and um
what's double about military bases it's
kind of like HomeTown Buffet style you
can put on as much food as you want and
whatever is laid there you could just
pile it on so breakfast I would always
go to The Omelette guy and I would tell
them like give me eight eggs
ham avocado like my breakfast were like
2 000 calories and I would pound it and
I would also get go to the salad bar you
know where they have like the
hard-boiled eggs that's like cold
peel a bunch of those so we're pounding
food and then we looked online and we
found uh these growth pills I don't know
if they work I mean obviously didn't
work growth for height specifically
height specifically and then your best
friend wanted it too no no it was just
for me because he was happy with his
height okay so we got these uh wait wait
so so you're revamping criteria or or
plan was get muscle no no this is our
this is our uh [__] I can't wait so we
both had a a vision okay our Visions
were the same except he has two goals I
have three
so his he already has a height no
problemo this so the first goal is
um is get bigger muscles okay that's the
unified goal unified goal the second one
is to come back with a bigger dick
obviously no one in the hood knows how
big our dicks are but we're like we're
gonna come back with some [__] big
dick how did you guys
come up with that the big dicks yeah so
it was just one guy brought it up or
were you both like hey I've seen your
dick I've seen my dick we're kind of the
same like how did that come about I mean
you'd be the only person that knows if
it was the same or not
foreign
okay uh so his ex-best friend is my
ex-boyfriend yeah so I would know
but I actually forgot anyway um well
good
um
I don't know
oh you know what
it's this
I think
we both have been to boot camp okay
boot camp is a wild place right you
spend a lot of naked time with 80 to 90
dudes because you guys uh have to shower
together shower together yeah that's the
only time you guys are naked yeah okay
so when you're with 80 or 90 dudes
a lot of Gossip happens after like what
like we'll be like dude did you see that
guy
that guy has a breakfast burrito
and you're like holy [__] [__] I
didn't even know right because dicks are
super important to guys yeah I don't
know why I remember I have no idea why
but it's ingrained in our [__] dumb
DNA okay it is and uh we're like dude
did you see how [__] fat
the [__] rooster was on that guy and
it's and so for us we're like
we need to get ours bigger I don't know
if ours is average I don't know if it's
below average above average I don't know
but we just see some guy that's just
walking around
with a straight up by 7-Eleven bean and
cheese burrito and some dudes you know
are silkies that in the military that
you wear some dudes are standing there
in formation and it just plops out
because it just [__] it just unravels
it's like taking a cinnamon roll and it
just roll it out and you're just like
whoa so that was our goal so starting to
hitting the weights pounding the food
okay wait what did you do okay go ahead
sorry sir and then uh we took I think we
took dick pills got some penis pumps and
I also got the hype pills
so those were the only goals yeah change
your body physically yeah get a bigger
dick yeah he stopped there you continue
with one more get the height and so I
remember going on the website I was like
Googling trying to like find like the
best high pill and then this one kind of
what does that look like
um it's it's the bottle is black no no
what is you searching and scouring the
[__] yeah like how to get taller like
hype pills whatever and then were you
reading reviews yeah there's like
transformation oh I was 5 10. I'm like
six one oh [__] that's pretty good I
just need like two inches
and so I would just read these reviews
I'm okay cool and then um were there any
side effects to any of them um okay the
thing that I read that I was always kind
of makes sense was I think one of them
was like cartilage based it was like
because of this it helps you grow with
cartilage so it puts like
um your cartilage between your spine
like it helps to grow that so like your
spine gets taller longer I'm like oh
that kind of makes sense so I bought
those pills how much were they I don't
remember I don't remember but yeah like
I would take them in the morning and
take them at night along with all my
other supplements like I was taking like
uh nitric oxide which is I mean just
like vasodilator protein like like my
multivitamin all that stuff I'll just
take all those and I had my my dick
pills and then I had my height pills
you're [__] lame dude I'm just
kidding after three months dick stayed
the same time and we're pumping too
there's times we're like I'd ask me did
you pump because we're trying to put the
we're trying to double it you know
because we thought if we take dick pills
and put get a dick pump and squeeze
squeeze what did the dick pill promise
um it doesn't it it's like it's like
PornHub like it just shows like a dick
and goes
and you're like whoa that's tight so it
doesn't it just it just looks like it's
way bigger
you know so we're like okay let's take
them I took those pills what what was
the selling point with the dick pump
where did you find this why did you even
hear about it was it's also good it's
just all like GIF ads you know like you
have a dick in a park were you on
PornHub and then they've just popped up
and you're like PornHub was backed in I
don't even know if it existed back then
okay but but you just see a dick in a
pump and you just see didn't you see
and you did that every day yeah we did
what is that what is that can you walk
me through what that is like yeah it's
pretty hot actually so you you get your
dick it has to be half chubbed complete
just whatever it is just what I found
what I found works the best is if you're
already hard so you had to bust a nut
first and then don't bust a nut you just
keep yourself hard
so then you well what would you do to
get yourself you watched some porn watch
some porn and then and how do you
prevent yourself from busting well you
bust after
okay so would it turn you on to pump it
no what the hey I'm just I'm I'm [__]
I'm a journalist right now all right the
the pump is on this side I'm just I'm
just doing the investigative work here
okay it's right here don't judge me okay
the pump is right I'm the [__] one
with the dick pump and the pills bro
okay the pump is right here
the pump okay it's right here okay I'm
not touching it I'm not even looking at
it I don't even know it exists okay I
cleaned it because I washed it the other
day okay I'm watching my porno and then
I'm jacking it it's hard now now I grab
it okay I put it on and then I try to
squeeze and try to like make it engorge
and get bigger did it work I uh not the
size part of it but does it get engorged
and does it look bigger it looks bigger
but now looking back I don't think your
dick gets bigger I think it just sucks
your dick in more uh so you know every
dude outside the the external dick every
dude has another like two to four inches
of dick inside
excuse me like when it's uh when it's
soft and then it grows or what are you
talking about no every dude whatever you
see on the outside has two to four
inches of dick inside instead of what
inside their body okay so your dick
isn't it's like if this isn't your dick
it's not attached to the skin and it's
just wobbling around the dick is inside
which is why you can't just bend the
dick all the way down when it's hard
right like when you when you try to pull
the dick down it goes because it has the
other parts inside okay stuck inside
okay so what I realized is so this is my
pubic area is it just sucked the inside
of the dick out more so it looks bigger
but what it is it's just a giant hickey
on my dick like it's pulling my dick out
yeah
um so it looks like it's growing but
it's not it's just pulling the inside
because when people have micro penis
that's the surgery like the ligaments
that are attaching the inside of their
dick they cut those ligaments so that
inside of the dick can now come out
that's the micropenis
um surgery surgery because you
technically have two to four more inches
like inside of your of your body yeah I
can understand your the concept that
you're talking about because when I
would pump our son's breast milk yeah to
keep him alive and give him nutrients
not just to waste my own time well I'm
pumping for your nutrients
well it didn't work did it I think
you're pretty tall
um what does that mean so it's so it's
in relation to my height that's why I
don't think it works because if I were
short it'd be huge is that what you're
saying no I'm saying my nutrients wasn't
really good when we swallowed every time
no I was already tall when I met you bro
anyway so
um I can relate to it because when I
would uh pump for taika you know it's
the sucking motion because it's getting
your breast milk out breast milk out
yeah uh it sucks to the point where like
your whole tit is like getting sucked
inside the [__] the tubing yeah so it
probably looks like your nipples are
getting longer but not really it's just
it's just like like cupping right yeah
like when you when you get cupping done
it's not like your back gets looser yeah
it's just the skin goes into the the
cups yeah uh what was
how long did you do it for
oh man I'm disciplined yeah
like two three months probably
oh so I would I would I would take my
pills
start pumping away and then take it off
and then I would jack off because you
got to finish you can't just let you
can't waste the boner and then do that
all the time and I'll wash it and then
uh we came back and
um we had another homie join us too
excuse me what do you mean join you join
you and join us in our quest uh to get
bigger dicks so it was just a big big
Quest yeah at this point so yeah did we
abandon the high and the the physique no
no so I came back obviously when I was
done
thinking I was gonna be like six feet
with a [__] 10 inch dick yeah and I
come back and I'm like five eight and a
half maybe and now probably a little bit
pudgy and uh I definitely put on muscle
um but my dick was the same size too so
I'm gonna accomplish one of the three
goals okay so then at that point when
you came back were you like this this is
stupid
I thought I was gonna come back and be
able to like you know bang on some fools
but I think everyone bang on some chicks
but I think everyone just goes oh that's
exactly the same bar I remember
right because you went in and came out
the same yeah they didn't see the
in-between of you losing like 30 pounds
yeah they're just like oh Bart's like
170 which is exactly what I remembered
when he left except they don't know that
I went down to 130 and I had to come all
the way back up yeah so then the homie
that joined you how did you get him to
join
um we're just talking about like dick
sizes all the time and then he was like
oh [__] like um he's like my dick is
actually pretty long but it's not wide
maybe I could get a wider I'm like yeah
dude you gotta join the join the crew
so he got his
and he was pumping away too I don't know
if um my crew in high school even
College was weird or not but we didn't
have those conversations we didn't have
the TD conversations we didn't have the
body conversation so were you guys like
not close no we were really close it
doesn't seem like you guys are good
friends
um but it maybe not
fine maybe not but yeah we didn't have
those conversations I wasn't on a quest
for any of that what kind of
conversations did you have that's more
important than titty size
you have
it was like relationship conversations
you know feelings
it's like my boyfriend did this we're
gonna do that or like work this or like
my career that you know things that yeah
you guys aren't close is that what it is
it sounds like dental office
conversations oh what do you do for a
living oh my uh I had to file taxes oh
really how old I see you're married oh
yeah I've been married for 15 years
maybe I'm not interested in it so maybe
they wanted to talk about that but I
could only see it from my own
perspective and I don't really give a
[__] about that [__] honestly yeah like
I don't care hearing about your [__]
and your titties like I don't I don't
care so maybe that's why maybe I'm the
[__] prude in that group no they're
like we can have this conversation with
this [__] this [__] is boring no I
think most girls don't think about it I
think it's a very guy thing guys are
weird yeah
um I can't recall buying anything
like that
like I don't think I bought any gimmicky
things like that it could also be
because I just didn't have money maybe
or maybe you're tall already you don't
need to
but I I did buy um I did buy into
um I was definitely into like my body
image so I always wanted to be slender
did you buy like uh what was that master
or a nav roller or AB cruncher no
luckily for me my mom already had like
the [__] what is it the stair climber
no no not the stair climber it was
Nordic Track yeah she had that she
already had a stationary bike so I was
definitely the only one in the whole
house using it yeah
um but I did buy that the the diet thing
that like the fat burner that they like
Hydroxycut I think maybe yeah that
Federal in it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
probably I had that in high in college
you like it oh man I was [__] like
this is this is like looking jaw
clenching and I was just gnarly that I'm
like okay this is weird I took that too
so I didn't take it for very long but
then that's when I realized that
everything's about diet because I would
eat exactly the same like fried chicken
pizza nothing changed yeah I'm just
cracked out and fat yeah
um the other thing I did do was like I
would follow
uh when I heard about like the lemon
cayenne pepper like that diet which is
like more of a you would call it like a
detox so you don't eat for a week or
some [__] like that it's so [__]
unhealthy for you yeah I even think I
did it while we were together yeah I
remember uh I remember us going to a
specific I don't know if it was a Trader
Joe's or a Whole Foods because it needs
a specific grade of maple syrup yeah and
it wasn't like the you can't just put on
Jamaica
um yeah I did that and I think that was
kind of the extent of the crazy [__] I
bought
I guess another gimmicky thing that I
you can say I bought was um maybe like a
push-up bra but that was that's the
extent of that yeah why do you ask about
the height thing I feel like it went on
a giant tangent no no no it's right
because I was watching a JK news clip on
Instagram where you said that was an
insecurity of yours and I've asked you
our entire relationship because
obviously or maybe it's not obvious I'm
taller than you by two feet
um so so you know we've always had this
conversation like does it not always but
at least in the beginning I had the
conversation with you like hey does it
make you feel uncomfortable that I'm
taller than you and I was always under
the impression that that didn't matter
to you so my height is with myself
like for you when you're 5 10 5 11
you're hot the Way You Are
but I didn't fulfill my own vision board
so that's nothing to do with you yeah
yeah yeah you know no no I know it has
nothing to do with me I'd say when you
were like oh I'm tall and I'm gonna wear
heels to this event I'm like yeah do you
yeah look as fabulous as gorgeous as you
want yeah it's you it's for me where um
I know like the the type of athlete I
wanted to be yeah and I wanted to like
my childhood hero was Michael Johnson do
you know who Michael Johnson is Michael
Johnson no at that time he was the
runner yeah the fastest man alive then I
do know him [__] jacked big ass legs
whatever and you know me I'm like a data
freak you know so I would like look up
all these people's stats and stuff and I
was like oh damn I noticed all of the
fastest people in the world are
generally between 5 10 5 11 because once
you get above 511 uh your femurs are too
long you start slowing down except Usain
Bolt he has
free free genetics where he's the only
one over six feet where um somehow the
way that his body is shaped
um he can't take off as fast as some of
his counterparts but the minute covers
more ground but the minute he hits like
the 20 meter 30 meter Mark he has that
extra seventh gear that no one has and
he's just pulling away you know he's
never the fastest off the takeoff but
Michael Johnson he would just look like
like a like a Van Damme I just like that
look where it's like you like an x-frame
balanced still Nimble and so I just
always wanted to be like a five eleven
six feet everyone that I ever like like
Reggie Bush running back everyone I just
liked was like around that height yeah
so that's what I I wanted to like or
even like uh Derek Fisher from the
Lakers yeah you know like I was like I
always wanted to be there and so as I
got older I didn't get there so I was
like oh [__] I just felt like damn I I
didn't become yeah who I wanted to be
yeah so I was like what can I do and I
started looking at the pills and all
that stuff and I think uh once I
realized there's just nothing I can do
then now it's up to me to accept it yeah
so I was like well [__] it you know yeah
I mean that's all literally you can do
unless you get some type of surgery
because it bugs you that much yeah but
then also like the right surgery right
like you can like get your tibia
extended but then you lose
um athleticism there's a huge chance to
lose athleticism because you have to
learn how to walk again your neurons
aren't attached to the same place your
muscles aren't attached to the same
place I have 30. your bones more
vulnerable right like you can break it I
don't know about that because I do know
they put metal plates in oh [__] but um
you I have 30 years of learning this
body
and if I start from scratch I I you're
starting as a baby of learning the extra
inch or two yeah right
um
so for me I was like it's probably not
worth to get a surgery like that I don't
wanna because for me it's about the
athlete it's not just about the looks
yeah and then I think at a certain point
I was like well this is what it is so I
just gotta live with what I got and be
happy with what I have so I'm not
insecure about it but then I think for
JK news I was answering more of uh what
would I change and that's what I would
change but I'm not insecure about that
anymore I see I see yeah because it did
catch me off guard because what I was
saying was you know during our
relationship excuse me it was something
that I brought up not because of of um
it having to do anything with me because
an insecurity is never on the other
person it's literally your own
insecurity yeah but some people put it
on other people yeah but that's immature
so people like don't wear heels because
you're gonna be taller than me or
whatever yeah if if you're one of those
people listening right now you it's it's
100 you like it's don't blame it on the
other person that's [__] up
um but because I've always been very uh
open about that and we've had
conversations about that when I heard
that it was an insecurity the way it was
presented it I mean it could all be a
misunderstanding at this point that I
was like what
so it did take me off guard and I was
like oh I want to talk about that that's
why I brought it up yeah so I didn't
think it was anything to do with me I
see yeah so I get it now it's definitely
not insecurity it's just your vision
board which is also
um something that I like we all have our
own vision boards whether we like to
believe it or not
um even now like I was telling you
earlier I even still have my own vision
board like I want to be
so my vision board for this next 30
years maybe even just 10 years of my
life but honestly for the rest of my
life this is my vision board for myself
so from uh now till I die this is my
vision board for myself I'll tell you
die yeah wow this is my vision board for
myself I always want to look capable
physically okay right so I want to look
capable physically and I want to be
physically capable so that's why I know
I'm I I constantly want to what's your
definition of capable though because
everyone's different too um I don't want
to be like
older like where I'm in my like 50s 60s
even 70 like I want to be like your mom
she's very physically capable you think
she's capable I think she's capable like
I've seen her uh climbing rocks and
stuff she gets on like the the all the
toy all the climbing toys at a park with
taika like for her age she's really
physically capable can she lift the
weights and do all that stuff probably
not not now because she's never done it
but we can build her up to it because
her foundation's really really good so
you just want to be like nimble and kind
of absolutely Mobility yeah because that
still gives me the option to build upon
it if I want to go into strength
strength training because when I think
capable I think triathlete
okay so we have different swim far run
far okay so we have different
definitions but that's my definition of
it to where if I need to run with my
grandkids or like I don't know I just
don't feel like I just don't want to be
held up held back by my physical
limitations because if you have a
physical limitation it's either
um self-induced or it's just unfortunate
you just have you know um bad genetics
so I want it to be one of those I don't
want it to be self-induced so if I can
control that I want to control it that's
one of them the other one is I want to
still be stylish like I still like I
don't I look at grandmas and I
understand where it comes from but for
my own vision board I always want to
look
well put together and I think it for me
remember this is my own opinion this is
my own vision board but for me when
I get older I know that it's quick to
look like a a faded version
of yourself right because now you have
gray hair your Skin's more pale like or
lighter like you just look old some
people rock it even better okay yes and
that's what I want to do like there's a
super artistic like whether interior
designers there they got like the red
brim glasses yeah and they Rock the
silver hair like really good that's
that's my vision board like I want to
look like that I don't want to just I
don't want to just fall into being old
and just now I'm just this Grandma you
know that like just does Grandma's [__]
yeah it's almost like as if you're
accepting your expiration date yeah so
it's like for me I just want to be
rocking it out until my my clock stops
you know so that's my vision board
um and obviously
um constantly working on myself and
doing all that like so that's never
going to stop because I just I'm always
going to try to achieve more out of
myself in in all aspects of mental and
like all of that but just the appearance
of it is that's that's what I want it to
be
yeah
so you don't have that for yourself my
vision board
um
I think I'm living my vision board
uh but so you would continue it this is
this is it till you die yeah I would
continue it um I think the person that I
want to be is someone that's physically
capable and for me that's like I want to
be strong and have endurance
um
and I want to be emotionally capable
like be there for you be there for our
kids
um and I want to be
um
sorry I'm not laughing it's just me I've
farted she's like right here I want to
be intellectually capable yeah which
that's that's something that I don't
think I have a problem with because I
you know like I'm like a
info junkie I just love learning
constantly about random things
but I want to keep progressing in that
way
yeah
the only thing that I'm insecure about
now that I don't even think is an
insecurity it's more of a reality is
that I can't fight
that's the only thing why what's your
definition of fight like I I can't
defend myself
um against whom like a [__]
professional fighter because uh against
the average American you can Falcon
dominate 90 of the people I can
um but it's gonna take some effort
like I want to be um
where I am
um like my definition of defending
myself I want to be able to do it like
with my eyes closed
but the only way to get that way is if
you've trained since you were like
[__] five or just train hardcore for
five to ten years
but pretty much like any purple belt
like in Jiu Jitsu you don't even have to
be blackball
any purple belt can go to almost 99 of
the situation and you can probably tie
both of their feet together or tie one
arm behind their back and they can
defend their sub themselves even from an
NFL linebacker you know like they they
just understand body mechanics
probability okay if there's this dance
there's only this many types of attack
that's going to come my way yeah but you
can get to that in five years I know
that's nothing but because I haven't
started that Journey oh it's still
something that you hold on to until you
start it and continue it yeah yeah got
it okay that makes it like one thing
that really resonated with me
um was I was hearing like this little
mini speech on Instagram reels by yako
shout outs to yako he's uh the main
combatives instructor
um at sheepdog response which is Tim
Kennedy's self-defense
um of course of course and what he was
saying is like
he was pretty much saying like everyone
has like a dark Zone black Zone and
black zone is when you give up you're
like holy [__] this is crazy my life's
gonna end whatever right and I think he
was saying like
um red zone is when like you feel really
really scared but you don't want to pull
the plug you don't need to like pull the
plug on yourself like it's really
dangerous but you there still might be a
little bit of Hope yellow is like other
situations like manageable it's like
whatever
and after I think whooping everyone's
ass in the whole class
he was letting everyone know he goes I
know most of you guys probably got to
the Red Zone today
um because we're not going to get you
into the black Zone which is probably
like 10 people surrounding you all with
guns and you're literally like just
shoot me then like no one's in a hostage
situation like that but he goes
dealing with everyone I never get in the
yellow zone not even I never get in the
way oh yeah I never get in the yellow
zone oh [__] he's like literally I'm
doing it for that he's like literally
like because I put myself in the
uncomfortable so much with black belts
that when I'm dealing with any common
regular person that's awesome it's
easier than like ironing my pants yeah
you know and that's what people mean by
uh when they say control what you can
I don't think like so you get you hear
that being thrown around specifically
like on Instagram and social media and
stuff that gets thrown out a lot and I
don't think a lot of people even
understand what that means and that's
literally an example of control what you
can and and putting yourself in
difficult situations so that when
something difficult happens in real life
it's not even that difficult or like you
don't panic you you're you're controlled
yeah yeah yeah it's it's you're whatever
your daily dues that you're paying is so
much harder than what is happening yeah
and that's the way you want to be you
want to be more prepared than life you
don't want life to hand you tests yeah
you know like you're like life
should be easier than what you dish out
to yourself yeah and uh when I heard
that I was like oh [__] like that's
that's
when I feel like I could defend myself
yeah when he is like
um literally anything that because if I
get into a scuffle like let's say if I'm
at a bar
and like something happens you're in a
yellow I'm like immediately in the
yellow and I'm already I have to gauge
like oh [__] what the [__] is gonna
happen like is this guy trained or I'm
like okay I'm like trying to assess does
this guy have any attributes oh this guy
looks like he has like big legs kind of
kick him like I have to think right
he doesn't have to think
like the minute someone grabs him he's
just like oh
you know it's just like
it's like if taika I can literally be
like this and tell taika to come attack
me from the back and nothing's gonna
happen right yeah like he's just gonna
come I'll just go like this and then
that's literally how he feels about it
everything every other full-sized adult
yeah and I'm like I want to get to that
level got it because then that is when I
feel like
you know I want to get to where you have
a million dollars in your bank and then
you're trying to make decisions on
something that costs 10 bucks versus
right now my self-defense is I have a
thousand dollars in the bank yeah and
every decision is like 500 or more yeah
so I can cover it but
is it going to take out half yeah like
that's that's what I mean got it that
makes sense yeah yeah that's a good
insecurity to have so for me but it's
also it's not even insecurity because
it's reality like I've been to enough
courses and I grapple with enough people
that anytime I go against someone high
level get my ass heading to me and I'm
like okay there it is that's the same
results that I've been expecting and uh
that's where I'm at yeah it never
changes yeah yeah those are cool
insecurities to have because it and I
still think it's an insecurity because
it's something that you're not happy
with and I think it's really good to
have insecurities
um because it really shows you where
your weaknesses are and how much you
care about yourself to want to see that
as something that's sticking out that
you don't like about yourself and now
the cool part is you have Choice yeah to
change it maybe that's where it is where
it's good to have your insecurity match
your reality yeah because then you can
change it because on the flip side the
typical frat bro or barbro
they're the ones that have 500 in their
bank account and they're like I'll buy
anything that's a million bucks yeah
that's just they've never been tested
you know so they're just like like dude
yeah bring in a UFC fighter in here
you know yeah that's uh that's just not
being self-aware man
well thank you for clearing that up uh
because I was definitely like wait a
minute
I mean it was it was one of those where
I'm like wait did I miss something here
what happened but no everything's
cleared up now I get it
um and I do like your insecurities even
though you don't really call them
insecurities you call them reality
because yeah it's only going to make you
a really dope person
um I have a ton of insecurities
ton yeah but they're all things that I
can control you know like
um
it's mainly more centered around wanting
to be more knowledgeable at things
just being smarter like I I mean to care
about like my cooking I'm like I'm
insecure about so many things
a ton but I know how to change those you
you want to be a way better cook
absolutely I want it I want to be
comfortable in area in area in every
area of my life oh yeah we're on like
what's your definition of comfortable
though where I have like a I have
answers to certain questions that do pop
up so in the kitchen for example what
are we gonna eat today right now I'd be
like [__] I don't know I'm just gonna
order something I don't want to think
about it because there's so much
thinking involved because I don't know
like I would have to sit there and
really strategize whereas if you've
exercised that muscle or if you've
learned enough about culinary arts then
you can just look at a couple
ingredients the way you do it like
you're not like a world-class chef but
you can definitely cook something up
that's yummy it's literally on the cover
of the book that you own what's it on
the cover of the book acid heat fat salt
if you have those four things it's gonna
taste yummy
so you start with the acid what do you
got you got some lemon juice you got
some vinegar you got some ponzu and then
a heat turn up the stove fat what do you
got some kind of protein like bacon you
got or even olive oil you know sometimes
something tastes kind of dry like when
you go to Subway you ever notice that
like if you don't tell them you just go
as is
when they make the cold cut trio they'll
take olive oil and put it in and then
but then when you eat it it's because oh
now there's like so much more uh it's
not dry it's not a dry sandwich so is it
Mayo you know you put some fat in there
and then salt seasoning yeah that's not
what I'm saying I'm just saying
um just being comfortable with that but
what I'm saying is I think to be
comfortable all you got to find is the
three or four things that make up
anything of course and that's what I'm
saying too that I want to find what
those are oh yes and then cooking I just
showed it to you now you're good well
I'm not good until I apply it and now
it's ingrained in me so kind of like
you're fighting it's like yeah you
understand in theory yeah and like you
can look at it but it's not until it's
applied and now you're tested yeah that
you're like oh [__] I need more work or
okay I'm pretty comfortable here sure
you got to test it yeah right so in
order to be comfortable you don't have
to think about it anymore it's just
second nature yeah something needs to
become second nature in order for you to
be comfortable with it right like you're
comfortable with breathing because you
don't think about it anymore because
it's it's part of who you are
um but if you're constantly thinking
about okay I gotta breathe in okay how
long do I breathe in for okay now I
gotta breathe out wait but how long
should I hold it like let me look in
this book do I need to hold it for 10
seconds two seconds but it's like now we
know you breathe in for one Let It Go
for one you know so it's like it's it's
it's thoughtless that's what I'm saying
I want to be comfortable in that way
where it's it's it it can be thoughtless
I see yeah that's what I mean
yeah so that's why huh what happened I
want you to size so hard oh because uh I
just needed to explain that oh yeah
because you were like teaching me about
cooking and I was like no no I get it
but you don't get it though I do get it
bro I'm just kidding I'm gonna [__] you
up
um so that's why when I first got breast
implants and people were like oh my gosh
she's so insecure like if she bases all
her identity uh with like her physical
stuff and I was just like oh man that's
so crazy that you guys don't see things
I mean now it's different right because
I've had these boobs for almost 10 years
now and things have progressed so much
and because of social media and stuff
you see how many people have you know
what the irony is what the people that
said you're insecure they're insecure
about you being insecure what do you
mean that's the irony what do you mean
because if they were secure
they wouldn't care about what you do oh
absolutely that's true so it's because
they've already latched their identity
yeah onto this Geo that they knew yeah
and they're like cool and then when this
Geo changes they're like why the [__]
did you change oh my God it's your
insecurity but this just did a
projection yeah yeah because they
finally found something that they
related to them you know yeah
um so yeah when that had happened or
when that happened and I was getting
that reception which wasn't even a lot
like everyone was super supportive and
wonderful with it but those but I see
that all the time it's like oh my God
what a Brad Pitt shave his head and it's
like
why not he could do whatever he wants
yeah you're insecure about someone
else's stuff yeah yeah um but it just
and I can see where they come from
because it paints a picture of like
you're not satisfied with who you are
and like what God gave you and all this
stuff and it's like duh but like who
says that's a bad thing like wanting
something different or having your
vision board of what you want it to look
like yeah
um and I think everyone should have a
vision board you know everyone should
always want to strive for bigger and
better
um without like having to obsess over it
or having it be unhealthy but definitely
always looking to becoming a better
version of yourself in every aspect like
a better friend a better lover a better
child a better civilian or a better um
uh citizen you know like all these we
can always be working on ourselves to be
better
um and and I don't think there's
anything wrong with wanting to
physically be better you know physically
capable uh physically
um
um well yeah capable but also looking
like you're capable you know I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
what's that one quote I think it's by
like Socrates or Plato
but they said it's uh it's pretty much
like
it's a tragedy if you live your life
without finding what you're physical
like limits or like yeah what your
body's capable of yeah it is it is a
tragedy because it's literally your own
like vehicle your own meat vehicle that
you get to go through life and it's a
tragedy to like
um not take the potential like turn the
potential to see what it's what you're
really made out of yeah yeah
um
yeah no absolutely we would have to make
time for it but and this is so CUNY
because this is something I was telling
taika because right now we're in a phase
where taika is very emotional about
things and if something is too
intimidating for him or he doesn't
understand it right away he he wants to
give up on it so he's about to do a jiu
jitsu competition this Saturday
and uh so there's a lot of tournament
classes that are happening so his normal
schedule is Monday through we'll say
Thursday he has Jiu Jitsu for one hour
now since it's tournament prep time he
has Jiu Jitsu for two hours a day now
and he had Jiu Jitsu on the weekends so
instead of training for four days a week
he's actually training for six days a
week so in all of that he was kind of
expressing that his body's a little bit
tired a little bit sore and he just
doesn't want to do it anymore he goes
and I'm like hey that's I'm like only
losers talk like that man like we're not
losers in this house like quons are not
losers
um he goes but I want to be a loser and
I'm like I'm like okay if you're a loser
because we were taught so kind of
backtracking a little bit more he wanted
to when you're in California he sleeps
in my bed when you come back it's like
bittersweet because he's super happy
that his Papa's back because he adores
you but then it's bitter because he no
longer gets to sleep with Mom he's
always questioning why so he's like why
can't I sleep with Mom and I'm like well
because
Papa's my husband and I'm his wife and
husband and wife we sleep together
um so he's like I want a wife so I'm
drawing from that ex that conversation
and pulling it into this loser
conversation and I'm like I'm like hey
but you know if you're a loser you're
not going to find a wife wives don't
like losers I'm like we need to be
winners okay and winners and being a
winner is not easy that's why
um uh being a loser is easy you know
because you just stop and you don't do
anything you don't move your body like
your body's not going to be you know
it's not going to be able to do
everything you want it to do your brain
you're not going to be able to like
think properly and like your wife's
talking about like I'm just kind of
laying it all out for him I'm like
winners have to work for it winning is
hard but because it's hard
um you get all these too so I'm just
like trying to break it down to him how
he needs to be a winner yeah um I forgot
how I got to this tangent because I got
so excited about talking to [__] yeah
talking about him what was my point I
was trying to make I don't know I was
drawing I was drawing the parallel of
what I just said about wanting more oh
wanting more for the Avatar and all that
stuff uh and I was I think basically I'm
just saying how I'm instilling that into
Taiko right now yeah of telling him like
being a winner or trying to achieve what
you want in life is never going to be
easy because it is supposed to be hard
because you've never done it before
so if it feels like you're in a hard
place right now that's where you want to
be because in order to be
where you see yourself in that vision
board or in the future you've never been
there that's why it's called the future
right it's not present it's future so in
order to get to the Future you have to
become a different version of yourself a
better version of yourself so that you
can get to your future that becomes your
new present and then you have another
vision board so that's what I was trying
to get to the bottom of yeah and that
that lesson I think is one of the most
important lessons you can teach not only
kids but anyone
because it has compounding returns yeah
like one of the biggest things that I
like thank my mom for yeah was
um when I was I don't know if I was like
in fifth grade or something I remember
going to Taiwan for a summer and uh we
stayed there for like a month or two
and at that age you learn stuff fast but
you also forget stuff fast and I came
back and I was a brown belt in kung fu
and I didn't want to go anymore because
I was like running through my thoughts I
was okay cool Monday we got to go to
school and then I have Kung Fu after and
I was like okay what are some of the
forms and I'm like oh my God not only do
I not remember my brown belt forms I
remember Greenbelt orange yellow I don't
remember any of the forms
and I remember my mom going okay we got
to go to Kung Fu and I started crying
like I was scared embarrassed yeah I was
embarrassed I was scared I felt like I
was starting with the white belt and I
just committed like four years of my
life to this you know and then my mom
pushed me and pushed me and pushed me
and finally I went and she's like you
know what like uh no stress because I
think she even talked to the seafood
about it and then the seafood was like
you know what no stress don't worry
about
because like when I put the belt on he's
like burden right you're a senior in
this place yeah he's like don't even
worry about and then the way a lot of
like martial art formations are it's the
highest belt in the front and then the
lowest belt in the back and goes come in
as a white belt don't wear a belt stand
in the back and then just use your eyes
and if you remember the form do the form
if you don't go sit down no stress
and I did it and it started coming back
real quick boom boom boom boom in no
time I got it then went from brown belt
took my red belt red belt got my black
belt and when I got my black belt it's
such a like such a long journey like
maybe like six seven year journey I got
a big certificate and I was like cool
like I actually
finished something before I finished
something like most people don't really
finish something until I graduate high
school yeah right that's their first
thing they're like oh [__] I just spent
12 years getting this thing
um I finally finished something as like
a 10 or 11 year old so I finished
something and the reason why I say it
has compounding returns is because in
every phase of life when you hit
something hard the last thing you think
about is the last hard thing you did
yeah and then you compare and that's
your internal motivation yeah you know
so now now when I'm like trying to study
trying to get into UCLA I'm like damn
ass four years that's all I'm gonna do I
just spent seven years eating a black
belt okay that's no problem I could do
it you know yeah and you need to do that
or even like in boot camp when it gets
hard and some people quit I'm like what
do you mean like I've been a monk for
like two weeks I have took a vowel
silence I remember what it's like to be
still for like hours at a time okay cool
so like that's why it's so important
yeah it's so hard I mean it's so hard
but so important to get people to a
place where they accomplish something
themselves so that the next hard thing
because life is just going to continue
getting harder when once they get harder
they think back to the last hard place
they were at and they're like okay what
were the tools that I had that and then
they're able to compare and get better
and better and better yeah yeah that's
called wisdom
yeah
yeah so um yeah that's one thing I I
definitely want to instill in taika
specifically is that is that like hey in
order to be a winner you have to feel
uncomfortable anytime you don't feel
uncomfortable you need to level up
yeah but yeah that was that's kind of
the extent of the conversation with the
five-year-old I I have to like make it
really small but it's really big lessons
yeah and it's really rad that I remind
them the next day because you completely
forgot them absolutely I mean
mid-sentence you probably already forgot
yeah if I told him hey what did I say
he's like I don't know I'm like all
right whatever something will stick at
some point I'm just keep throwing [__]
at his way I remember we're giving him
like a pretty deep lesson this morning
and then while we're like changing them
for school and goes I like this shirt
I was like all right I'm like every
every day it's like a sculpture you know
so it's like that's what it is like two
chips a day we do that now yeah yeah
we're [__] about to be 40 and we do
that now like how many times like have
you been like I've been saying that to
you and it finally clicks very true you
know or or I do that to you I'm like
dude I've been telling you that and
you're like but now I get it yeah it's
the same thing we're gonna we're never
gonna stop doing that [__] but damn I
thought I was gonna catch you in an
insecurity and be like aha you're a
[__] mortal I'm Immortal he's talking
about I know you're Immortal I just
think I thought it would be CUNY oh but
I guess I was wrong
thanks for lying to everybody what I'm
just kidding all right on that note
I'm gonna wrap it up here but before I
do you have something to say
this podcast brought to you by barbell
Brigade we literally do our best to make
the sickest gear all the time we got
dope teas dope hoodies like this hoodie
from the shadow collection and we're
always dropping new dope [__] all the
time supplements to taste bomb highly
effective with clinically proven
ingredients and right now we have our
get strong program which is the exact
same program I'm running to get this to
become the strongest version that I can
be so if you ever want dope Fitness Gear
go to bottlebrigade.com it's me and my
Bears brand we spent a lot of our time
and energy making sure everything is
super sick so go check it out go support
and see you guys next time bye